in French or in English on stage or on
screen performing or directing she is
the totally captivating definition of
the word woman janma ho
if ever you were loud on a film stage
you feel a very strange presence and you
think who is that person who wanders
about the set getting into everybody's
business for 30 60 90 days and night and
sometimes much more that person keeps up
the spirit criticized without hurting
binds imaginary wounds is a nursemaid a
psychiatrist shrink you know father
mother brother sister everything and
that person is the director a year
before the actors loved the project the
director miss Lovett a year after the
film is finished shooting in the final
cutting and scoring
you must try still harder to love it
more most directors should be mad but
they are just mildly insane and their
overall motto is I love this you love it
too or quit my army and join another and
the nominees for the directing award are
Alan J Pakula all the president's men
Ingmar Bergman face-to-face
signal Lumet Network
John G avildsen Rocky
Leena VAT moolah seven beauties
and the winner is
John gee
oh my goodness
I guess what rocky did was give a lot of
people hope and that was never a better
feeling than doing that tonight a lot of
people who gave me things Sylvester
Stallone gave me his guts in his heart
and his best shot thank you Thank You
Jean Kirkwood the executive producer
gave me a telephone call and said I got
a script here and it's called Rocky and
I think you'll like it
Thank You gene bill conti the musical
director of this show gave me the
inspiration with his beautiful music
Jim Craig my cameraman gave me his eyes
my cast gave me their talent Talia and
Bert burgess Carl Weathers Joe spinel
and Jimmy Gambino gave us the knowledge
of his fighting in Philadelphia I had
men giving me their energy Lloyd Kaufman
Roy ralph botta Mike Scott Joe Leticia
Garrett Brown and Ralf Hotchkiss and at
United Artists I had some men give me
their confidence Mike Medavoy and Eric
Glasgow and bob charde off and Irwin
Winkler thank you my agent my agent
Marvin Moss gave me besides some very
good recipes his counsel Holly hein gave
me her wisdom Melissa appleson and
Anthony avildsen my son and Rufus
Appleton my son who helped me pick the
locations in Philadelphia gave me their
love and thank you all very much
you